alarm ist herzlich willkommen wir heute
meine damen und herren zu einem weiteren
travel flock vor allem weiteren hat sich
das du täglich machen der eiffelturm
ich habe meine jungs
ich habe meinen anschlusszug verpasst
und will jetzt hier grad in fulda die
leute sind es mich fulda oder dem zug
so langsam weil sie echt nicht was ich
machen sollte ich habe meine freunde
gefunden deren bruder elia hat mich
abgeholt und rettet mich für meine hände
besitzen jetzt im auto und gehen jetzt
auch ganz kulinarisch was essen eben
[Musik]
reichensachsen
da darfst du ja dann leider nicht hin
deute der ausblick hier ist ein mega
krass nicht an vielleicht sind es so ein
bisschen ja und sie zwar noch nicht so
richtig aber der ausblick ist auf jeden
fall mega krass ich bin ganz kurz hier
vorne steht mein bett und das war's auch
schon wieder
ich habe insgesamt drei stunden 30
geschlafen und wisst ihr warum weil
diese kette jugendherberge sucht gott
verdammt lautet gewürzt wenn man jung
förderung und ist wenn diese bilder von
sport1 gut und wichtig wie früher ist es
stockfinster draußen zudem konnte ich
dann halt gestern nacht nicht kennen und
war danach sauer auf toilette schöner in
abseilen und dann gestoppt nur scheiße
aus den weisen die werden bahn versteht
aber sie schießen haben ein paar minus
40 grad
ich fühle mich den pinguinen allerdings
ist nach was mich cool ist aufgefallen
und zwar wenn man bei dem wort luca die
buchstaben l und zé tauscht kommt akku
leer aus er ist so cool bin zufall ich
ja ich glaube ja scheiße gebaut wir sind
jetzt beim dreh angekommen der
bundespolizei als beispielsweise ein
auto von denen hier hinten werden halt
die hunde darin gelagerte japan steigen
da vorne ist einfach so und jetzt auch
ein hund geht reden ja gerade freunde
mittagspause gefahren gerade zum eingang
nach vorne weil da zwei zuschauerinnen
bestehen und ich will jetzt ein stück
hier von einer tonne pizza vorbeibringen
oder ein stück pizza auch nicht grad
pause und ich hab es mitgenommen spielen
jetzt hier auf dem beamer eine
begeisterung im publikum
auf einem fuß ja nicht ganz jetzt
erstmal gerichts und dann drängt
das polizist ich habe jetzt gerade eine
uv taschenlampe entdecken cook bedeutet
selbst bisschen dreckig auch diese hürde
haben abgedreht für heute wir waren von
8 9 uhr bis jetzt um 19 uhr am drehen
ist aber auf jeden fall mega viel spaß
man fahrzeuge verzerrt ich wollte mich
mal ganz kurz vor euch dafür bedanken
dass sie mir sozial weil ich immer
videos und bilder schickt auf denen ich
markiere die cpu kapitza 3 ist ein hat
mir besonders gut gefallen
das in europa tätig so richtig perfekt
ist so erstelle die rheiner von wärme
gerade die bleibt die ganze zeit so dies
wird schon irgendwie dass sie plötzlich
richtig kalt wieder los und ihren halben
herzen sagt bekommen ich bin mir
eigentlich besser mit meldet einen
fahrstuhl und noch weiter hier morgen
dieser moment in der manager die
schreibt habe eine wette am laufen das
noch heute nicht zu spät zur abfahrt
kommst helfen nun zu spät schreibtisch
daneben will ja heute unbedingt
ausprobieren dieses aber ist als andere
weil es geht aber ich will die seite gut
drauf der welt
jeder der sich jetzt umdreht stinkt nach
scheiße kobe wie ihr bereits seht ihr
nichts denn es dunkel und wir haben
tatsächlich jetzt den ganzen tag gedreht
und das machen jetzt noch weiter das
heißt ich melde mich gleich wieder wenn
ich im hotel bin ich möchte noch kurzen
blick für die kamera ungerne kleine
rohde die person neben dem zimmer hat
glaube ich gerade fed geschissen
allerdings ein paar leute aus der luke
schon getroffen die formen gelände auf
uns gewartet habe und habe mir ganz
persönlichen t shirt gemacht wo einfach
alle instagram namen von hinnen darauf
standen also danke auf jeden fall an der
stelle werde ich definitiv jetzt jeden
tag locken ich gehe es allerdings erst
mal ich habe wiederum die anderen nicht
am besten beschreibt an der
hotelrezeption wurde ein brief für
jugendliche abgegeben von einer
zuschauerin auf jeden fall hat es in dem
brief die ihre handynummer mit rein
geschrieben das heißt wir rufen sie
jetzt mal auf anonym an die wir wieder
auf maximal drei bier getrunken
die geldstrafen
am besten gegen fahrstuhl beschützen
kann der tag nicht starten und frühstück
mit elf jahren
julia ist übrigens schauspielerinnen und
schauspieler dass jetzt etwas vor
einmal haben wir übrigens bei uns im
aufenthaltsraum und eine kaffeemaschine
dass die armenische als wir das dann so
schlauch ziehen und pfeife rauchen kurze
frage am rande schreibt oder eine
schreib mal gerne in die kommentare
ich verrate ich jetzt in polizisten den
[Musik]
da gibt es einfach ein jäger oder
zigarren abschnitts mit kartoffeln oder
nudeln iphone doktor geht schon noch
immer nicht so gesund austoben aber das
glauben sie doch nicht so gesund aus
hundertwassers der mir festgemacht hier
trainiert die bundespolizei haben die
beispielsweise eine kneipe aufgebaut und
hier so wohnungen da oben haben wir dann
so ein paar opfer rumstehen mit
realistischen dunkel draußen allerdings
haben wir gerade den letzten stunden
komplett viel gedreht
das war richtig krasse sachen hier mal
kurz ausschnitten ich schon in meiner
instagram story hatte ich bin schon ich
koste bundespolizist crew
dumme kuh der häfen vergessen zu fällen
dafür sind jetzt hier ja manchmal fühle
ich mich als wenn man noch so wäre so
wie wenn man für eine kamera entdeckte
von unseren fünfjähriger fachkraft man
sieht den augen
jetzt sagen ich geh schlafen wir machen
das in seiner bar und ich habe bestimmt
ein paar bier getrunken aber ich kann
trotzdem noch sagen dass 3,14 19 ist
[Musik]
ich habe es von katar wollte ist auf
jeden fall der letzte drehtag das heißt
wir drehen heute die letzten sachen die
meere ist eine challenge gegen julia und
zwar galgenmännchen herzlich willkommen
zur youtube
[Musik]
die ärzte sehen sich nach dem einfall
wie weit es mit dieser taktik her guckt
helbach gedacht ich muss doch jetzt
drauf kommen wenn ich liebe es im safe
[Musik]
die nicht richtig weiß schwarz igel abel
finden
[Musik]
ja das gibt es abhilfe bei dem nicht nur
noch leere gehen doch irgendwie scheiße
dann zählt das nicht immer manchmal
nicht was da noch nicht machen
[Musik]
hättest du den dom
das ist schon eine ganz andere kann ich
ein kleiner tipp geben muss jetzt
verraten aber darf ich ein kleines kind
ich habe auch keine tipps bekommen aber
das erste ist gerne viel zeit vergangen
freunde ich mir wieder in köln
angekommen und ich bin hundemüde es sich
jetzt auf jeden fall auch direkt
schlafen wenn euch der block gefallen
hat aber von meiner reise nach eschwege
mit unter anderem julia mit ilja und
noch mit ganz vielen anderen leuten das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
da wollte dass ich öfter so dumm blogger
dann schreibt uns in den kommentaren
abonniert main kanal weil dann für den
[Musik]
ein